واحد
مقاطع فيديو لكن البلورات تبدأ في التمزق
ركع على ركبتيه ليسقط ولحظة واحدة
سحابة بيضاء من الغبار لن تسمح لي بذلك
انزلاق اليأس لإغلاق المقصورة
زجاج التابلويد والخروج على
ضد من أين يأتي الخطر
سلام
[موسيقى]
لم يكن حدثًا كما تعلمون
وسائل الاعلام الدولية جدا
المنحرفة للتشويش وحتى الوصول إليها
أن يكون حادثًا مؤسفًا
سيء الحظ جدا
ويبدو أنه يرتدي حولها
[موسيقى]
في عملية تحديد الهوية
الجثث بين السلطات
وزارة الداخلية ولدينا
المتخصصين في المركز الطبي
قانوني وفي الساعات القليلة القادمة
هوية
بالمباراة
اين كان هو
لذلك لم يكن في العملية الإعدادية بحد ذاتها
أعدت ل
تبدأ عملها في العاشر من
مارتن
وكان بإمكاني رؤية الناس وهم يهتفون بـ
الناس الدخان المتصاعد من
كوارث فيلم